every year as a few disasters mixed him
with the masterpieces and 2017 wasn't
any different more the year produced
some truly great films had also had its
fair share of clunkers for malformed
horror movies and badly made biopics too
overbearing blockbusters that might just
give you a migraine
here are the worst movies of 2017 the
snowman on paper the snowman should have
been awesome is headlined by several
formidable stars and was directed by
Tomas Alfredson director of
well-received films like Let The Right
One In and Tinker Tailor Soldier Spy
Birth despite all that talent the film
is a bloody mess based on the novel by
Jo Nesbo the Snowman follows an
alcoholic detective who chases a psycho
with a thing for building snowmen
unfortunately the thrills are outdone by
a slew of messy subplots over-the-top
music subpar performances and a bunch of
supposedly freaky Frosty's that really
are not frightening the bye-bye man with
movies like split get out and it comes
at night 2017 was a pretty solid year
for horror but on the flip side we also
got the bye bye man written by jonathan
penner
and directed by stacey title this
january flight fleck has been described
as one of the emptiest nonsensical
haunted thrillers ever to fail genre
audiences and for good reason as a movie
it fails on every level imaginable from
the acting to the directing and worst of
all the bad guys mythology doesn't
actually make any sense what's up with
the coins what's up with the Train
what's up with the CGI mess of a
hellhound so yeah don't say it don't
think it
and definitely don't watch it they watch
based on the hit TV show starring David
Hasselhoff and Pamela Anderson
Baywatch looked pretty good on paper it
stars Dwayne Johnson and Zac Efron are
super shredded lifeguards who spend
their days saving lives cracking jokes
and fighting crime
but after Baywatch hit theaters in May
2017 critics immediately slammed the
movie for being well bad so what's up
with the hate maybe it's because the
movie focused a little too much on jokes
involving body parts and fluids it's not
hard to see why critics didn't feel the
need to save this movie from drowning at
the box office
underworld blood was Kate Beckinsale has
been playing the character of Selene
since 2003 in other words she's been
making the underworld movies for a long
long time it's a shame most of them are
terrible keeping with tradition
underworld blood Wars lives up to the
franchise's monstrously awful reputation
as usual the plotters vampires fight to
werewolves and Selene wears a lot of
leather the directing is uninspired that
dialogue gets stilted and it may just be
the bluest movie ever made in other
words it's probably time to drive a
stake through this franchise's heart and
let Kate Beckinsale move on to bigger
and better things she's killed enough
likens for one lifetime The Mummy
ever since I a man burst onto the screen
in 2008 movie studios have desperately
been trying to copy the map or model now
we've got the dark universe an attempt
by Universal to cash in on the
interconnected movie franchise craze but
instead of relying on talking McCune
Zoar Thunder gods the dark universe is
reviving classic movie monsters like the
Bride of Frankenstein The Invisible Man
and The Mummy
unfortunately for universal they bungled
their whole rebooted universe thing
right out of the gate The Mummy bombed
at a domestic box-office and the film
was savaged by critics from the opening
scene involving Iraqi insurgents to the
undead mummy herself few critics found
anything positive to say about the film
worst of all the mummy tried to set up a
Cinematic Universe in just two hours
whereas the MCU unfolded over several
movies by trying to lay the framework
for a future franchise in just one go
the story suffered as a result The Mummy
hasn't done much to brighten up the
future of universals dark universe the
circle of some movies you can tell right
away that they're going to be awful but
when some films bomb it's a little more
surprising take the circle for example
it's based on a novel by award-winning
author Dave Eggers and it features a
who's who of big Hollywood names
including Emma Watson John boyega and
Tom Hanks the plot centers on a creepy
Internet corporation known as the circle
which wants to create a world where
privacy is a thing of the past
unfortunately the film hits you right
over the head with its message as the
Atlantic cutter it's all like an episode
of black mirror if black mirror made no
effort whatsoever to be subtle the emoji
movie you might think a movie featuring
Patrick Stewart as a walking talking
piece of poop would at least be worth
watching as a gag but the emoji movie is
such a solar slug it deprives you of
even that simple pleasure you are
just doing my beauty it's a movie that's
supposedly about being true to yourself
but really it's just a big commercial
for Spotify candy crush and Sony a lot
of people scoffed at the idea of this
movie when it was first announced and
rightfully so the film was obliterated
by critics even though it still turned a
profit at the box office because kids
are the worst
birth up the dragon making a movie about
Bruce Lee should be the easiest thing in
the world he was a martial arts master
with a rags to riches story a truckload
of charisma and the tragic demise it's
the perfect recipe for an awesome biopic
but unfortunately director george nolfi
ended up making the worst kung-fu flick
of 2017 were the birth of the Dragon you
have offended my family and you have
offended a Shaolin Temple Dragon sent us
on the infamous 1964 showdown between
Lee and Wong Jack man only instead of
focusing on either of these legendary
figures the movie spends way too much
time following a white guy named Steve
who trains with Lee sympathizers with
Wong and wants to save his Chinese
girlfriend from a crime boss this isn't
the movie anyone paid to say were still
the film portrays Lee as an egocentric
jerk who needs a good beating which is a
weird way to depict one of the most
likable movie stars of all time daddy's
home too when the original daddy's home
hit theaters in 2016 it scored a measly
31 percent approval rating on Rotten
Tomatoes so why make a sequel and why
release it during the holidays
simply put because of the money that's
what Christmas is all about it's
Christmas thank you daddy's home two
picks up with Brad and dusty having
become BFFs and excellent Co dads but
the status quo is torn apart when the
grandpa's show up there's Brad's dad who
keeps kissing his grown-up son on the
lips and then there's Dusty's old man a
womanizing jerk but it's paying for
holiday humor daddy's home too is the
kind of movie that might inspire a new
generation of grinches to swear off
Christmas for good of the shack in 2007
author William P young published the
shack a best-selling novel about grief
guilt and God ten years later it was
turned into a movie starring Sam
Worthington Octavia Spencer and Tim
McGraw and spoiler alert one of those
actors literally plays God variety's
summed it up as a Hallmark card therapy
session which is putting it nicely if
you're looking for deep truths about
religion
you're better off looking just about
anywhere else
look on the bright side of
nope you won't find any answers to
life's big questions here unless you
wanted to know if God is a Neil Young
fan second spoiler alert yep
on the other hand you will get to see
some Worthington raised Jesus across a
lake so there's that of the house you
can hire all the comedians you want but
if you don't have a solid script then
your movie won't get any laughs that was
a problem with the house the latest from
Andrew J Cohen and Brendan O'Brien of
neighbors and Mike and Dave need wedding
dates Fame although the house boasts the
talents of Will Ferrell and Amy Poehler
instead of giving them a strong
screenplay to work with which we were
kind of counting on it leans almost
exclusively on their improv skills the
so called comedy revolves around a pair
of parents who open a casino in their
friend's house to raise tuition money
for their daughter where things spin
wildly out of control
soon the to become suburbanite mobsters
using drugs and chopping off fingers
while it seems like this wacky premise
could lead to some good gags most of the
jokes failed to land earth critics or
those few audience members who bothered
to watch bright theoretically bright
sounds like it should be pretty awesome
a cop movie set in an alternate universe
where orcs and humans live side by side
yeah it sounds goofy but it sounds like
the right kind of goofy but while
there's a rich mythology here to explore
the world of bright feels incredibly
two-dimensional the action scenes like
any real spark and while joel edgerton
tries to salvage the film with the best
performance he can muster under order
orc make up the script isn't doing him
any favors Plus whenever Smith starts
dropping lines like this fairy lives
don't matter today it's probably time to
press pause and revisit pretty much
anything else on Netflix all eyes on me
Tupac Shakur was one of the most
influential artists of his generation
and he definitely deserved a better
biopic than all eyes on me the movie
glosses heavily over the rapper's career
hitting the basic highlights instead of
really digging into his life as many
critics have pointed out the film plays
more like a Wikipedia page for an actual
movie he is hoping that one day some
future filmmaker will make a two-part
movie that tells a bit deeper into the
artists life Flatliners when the
original flatline is dropped into
theaters back in 1990 it made a pretty
penny at the box office but still failed
to impress many critics come
to 2017 sudo sequel though the original
feels like an absolute masterpiece of
horror the film follows a group of med
students experimenting with life after
life their tests involved taking some
heavy-duty drugs sopping their hearts
for a minute or two and checking out the
other side before being resuscitated
naturally messing around with the
afterlife has serious consequences but
when our heroes start experiencing some
spooky visions the film devolves into
jump scare the movie critics called out
the film's lack of suspense foolish
characters and lacking visuals leading
many to wish the property would have
just stayed where it belonged
in the afterlife thanks for watching
click the loop icon to subscribe to our
youtube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your loved team
[Music]